as a teenager kyra bell wanted to become
a boy
now she sees the transition she
underwent as a temporary and superficial
fix
for a complex identity issue that's why
she brought her case to the high court
arguing that children should not be able
to give informed consent
to receive hormone blocking drugs
delaying puberty
when i was put on the hormone blockers i
had no real idea of how it was going to
affect me
in reality on a day-to-day basis and
you know i was just very eager to get on
the
cross-sex hormone the legal action
against the tavistock and portman nhs
trust
which runs the country's only gender
identity clinic for children
is also being taken by the mother of a
16 year old on the waiting list for
treatment
it's the age kira was when she started
taking the hormone blockers
prescribed for some not yet out of
primary school
are they able to understand the nature
of the information that they are
being given so they have sufficient life
experience
and we say for children as young as 10
11 12
to be able to weigh up the loss of
fertility the loss of sexual function
is simply not possible but the barrister
representing the gender identity service
told the court that it was up to
clinicians to ensure the child
understood the consequences before being
prescribed any drugs
and that such decisions follow robust
international guidelines
vanilla morris qc explains how
prescribing puberty blockers
allows time for further discussion and
deliberation
about how to proceed in the future and
the effects are in fact
reversible there are many like alex
vellens
who have no regrets he says the journey
to being prescribed the medication
was very thorough obviously i understand
why
the process exists and they were like no
we have to wait
we have to give the four to six
appointments that are necessary across
six months it took me
18 months to get on them for whatever
reason but
my point is it took a long time and it
was really frustrating and i understand
why it takes a long time but please
don't make it take any longer time
kira's experience has been very
different
she stopped taking testosterone last
year now she's left regretting the
decisions she made as a teenager
it's a path she wants to prevent others
from following
she'll have to wait a few weeks to hear
the court's decision
emma birchly sky news